well what a day of chess it was magnus
carson's non-defeated streak has come to an
end it's taken 125 games and the dude
abides duda from poland has taken him down
it was a brilliant game the last time magnus
lost was on july the 31st 2018 and it took quite
special play from duda to achieve
it so let's go into the action
and duda had the white pieces magnus carlsen with
black goes for the karakan the thing i like about
magnus's play even though he's got this undefeated
streak he picks a very risky line knight to f6 and
this is a very dynamic line the last time magnus
played this was against peter svidler in 2018 and
apparently he said after the game to david howe
that he was never going to play this move again
here he is here he is with another loss probably
won't be doing it again and the point of this move
is that after the capture on f6 black takes with
the e pawn getting this unbalanced pawn structure
when the black king castles king side it's got
an extra pawn defending it the downside of this
is that white has this majority of pawns over
here on the queen side which later on can be very
strong especially as white has an easy way to get
a past pawn so structurally speaking bad but maybe
piecewise okay for magnus now the game continued
with theoretical moves they both developed in a
standard fashion both sides trying to get their
kings safe and black gets castle quickly and now
after queen c2 the main move check and then
h5 this is an important move in this variation
black uses this pawn often to cause some problems
if white castles this way and removes it from
harm's way white simply develops with bishop e3
and now black plays knight d7 trying to get those
pieces into the game white goes queen side it's
actually quite risky for white's castle king side
in this position because later on black can get
quite an initiative with the black knight coming
around towards the king and also this queen coming
on this diagonal so queen side castling leads to
this very unique and dynamic position here
now magnus plays move that's only been tried
once or twice before mainly by the young
dutch talent jordan van furiste and that was
the aggressive move b5 and this just shows that
magnus is in the mood for some action they do say
fortune favors the brave maybe that didn't happen
here well i know i've given the result away but
i think it had to be given away in this game i
know you're going to complain about that but come
on it's big news i've got to tell you and this
move b5 just shows that spirit of going for it
it might not work in the like short
term but in the long term surely fortune
favors the brave and magnus has shown this
throughout his last couple of years in chess
the other move here would have been knight to f8
a much more solid approach but b5 it is and now
to dude's credit he goes for the most ambitious
move d5 this practically forces magnus to play c5
sacrificing the pawn on b5 now i would never
consider capturing this pawn myself because
after bishop takes b5 you open up a line towards
your king but this shows the development of modern
chess in modern modern era we could say people
are much braver and they rely on their defensive
capabilities to a much higher degree this is
because most players use computers to analyze with
computers show better ways to defend and modern
players are learning how to grab that dangerous
pawn the poison pawn and then hang tough defend
you know what saran would say grab that pawn
magnus now plays rook to b8 that line is now for
the rook another interesting idea i was thinking
about here afterwards was maybe you could force
that bishop to a4 and try a move such as rook
e5 the idea of this is to get the rook off that
diagonal so you can try to play knight b6 next
move this could be something to investigate
in the future but rook b8 seems very natural
and now c4 might as well cement that bishop and
here magnus plays a6 a very logical move it's very
interesting to see that ex-world champion kramnik
bit of the legend all round suggested rook takes
e3 here giving up more material and this is a very
anti-computer move the computers hate this move
but kramnik's idea is that after pawn takes
the black knight cements itself here and white
doesn't have moves like f4 to get rid of that
knight this is a very interesting way to play
the computers really don't like it but i like what
kramnik's saying here it's great chances to start
an attack somewhere on the queen side so a very
interesting possibility magnus plays a6 and now
the bishop retreats to a4 and he gow plays rook e7
this has a similar idea to what we've seen before
the knight wants to centralize the rook wants to
come over here white plays a good move knight to
g3 also thinking about attacking and bringing that
knight to one of these attractive light squares
black continuous plan knight to e5 and now
knight to e4 a very human move in actual fact
a better move here would have been the pre-emptive
bishop d2 the idea of this move is to stop
the maneuver that we see in a minute the rook
coming around to b4 the bishop later on will also
be quite comfortable on this diagonal in the game
knight to e4 allowed rook to b7 duda had a long
think here but he can't really allow rook takes b2
ideas and he has to play b3 i think the reason he
had a long thinkers because he was working out
the complexities that were going to occur after
the following exchange sack and this is full steam
ahead magnus now he really wanted to win this game
just showing that risk factor was very brave but
again duda has to have all the credit for keeping
him at arms bay the dude was in good form last
time he defeated magnus carson the prime minister
of poland actually rung him up and congratulated
him so i wonder if he's going to get that phone
call again tonight i'm sure he deserves it it's
great to see these prime ministers and people
showing so much interest in the game can you
imagine that in america trump giving you a little
call after you beat magnus hey donald yeah yeah
okay yeah don't breathe on me yep it's okay okay
but anyway on to the game rook to b4 and magnus
keeps throwing those pieces into the position rook
takes a4 and again to the human eye this looks
incredibly dangerous for white because now the
rook is lined up it's a pity this pawn on c5 is
in the way because otherwise bishop to a3 would be
a stunningly dangerous move but magnus continues
developing he can't get his queen in the attack if
that queen could get in the attack it'd be great
but queen b6 doesn't really achieve anything here
it's not coming in it has no entrance points in
the position and remember what white has to do
here is just survive try to make some exchanges
and win the ending bishop to f5 that piece comes
in and now after rookie one i would say the losing
move h4 this is just far too slow here it's rare
to see magnus go wrong but he needed to play
with a little bit more urgency in the position
and the defensive play from white here is simply
simply astonishing knight g4 would have been a
much better move trying to create complications
and entering straight into tactics the point of
this move is that after something like f3 magnus
could have captured the knight and now play a move
such bishop e5 the rook now wants to come into
b2 and after let's say bishop to c3 here which
i think must be the normal move the bishop
moves into d4 and even this queen can now sneak
into e5 and black has more inroads into white's
position here so h4 was far too slow and now h3
stops any of these shenanigans with that knight
darting into the position the knight therefore
tries to find another route in but now another
great move the rook comes centralized allowing
the other rook to come in and in some cases it
can make exchanges when your material up you want
to exchange pieces off the board magnus throws
the knight in and now g4 forcing the bishop back
and again this next move real real class king to
d1 i mean seriously how many players would think
of this move just trying to get the king away from
a potentially dangerous place on the queen side
it's a weird little maneuver and even though
the king still looks like it's under a lot of
frets here there's no obvious way that black can
increase the pressure that's magnus's problem here
he plays a very human move f5 trying to break
open the position but now white makes some more
exchanges and he simply takes on f5 again
both players showing no fear here you give
me a poor magnus um i will take it i am the polish
pac-man i'm gonna munch my way through your pawns
and pieces boy you may be world champion but i'm
going to eat them all magnus idea he gets a check
but again duder blocks that with f3 black queen
now comes to a potentially dangerous diagonal
but it's blocked again bishop c3 and
we can see here that white's starting
to get quite a harmonious position and even some
counter-attacking chances with this strong piece
black's only try is to try to get the queen
into the position via the g file but now queen
e4 centralizing queen to g2 and rook e1 again
very nice centralization of the pieces here
even here as white i'd be scared after magnus's
move queen takes a2 i'll be like oh come on man
give us a break he's threatening such ideas a
rook b1 but the way to get through these kind of
positions you just have to calculate and show no
fear try to exchange try to swap off and there's
only one move here but it's a good one queen c2
offering the exchange of queens and now the king
can come to d2 because we're blocking that force
field from the queen queen takes c4 rook to e8
check this force is off well more pieces i mean
the other options here were just as bad magnus's
idea here is to try to complicate things by at
least giving himself a check on d5 when the chips
are down and you're struggling you might as well
throw everything into the pot there's there's no
point you know fading away you might as well burn
in a blaze of glory and i think that's what magnus
is aiming to do here but white has so many
pieces now as we can see his material up and
as long as he holds his nerve here which he does
very well he can get to the victory line and there
may have been easier ways for white to have won
this but it's always nice having two extra rooks
magnus fights on and now in this position
duda takes quite a practical choice
the best thing to do is when you're winning you
know simplification is good but if you see an
opportunity to attack you have to calculate it and
in this position queen d8 would have actually been
not the move that behaved but a much better idea
giving up your rook but forcing the black king
out into the open and we can see after a series
of checks that the black king is in hopeless
situation this kind of sequence will end with
the black queen being lost so duder gives magnus
a glimp glimpse of hope there with rook f8
but again after king c1 magnus has no checks
and there's really no way in white's pieces
are stopping everything so the game goes on but
eventually duda manages to get some coordination
creates some threats of his own black has to now
defend and as we see magnus's only idea let's go
back to that point there where he gets a check
in magnus magnus's only idea around this moment
is to try some desperation checks the white king
moves up the board and here a very practical
choice this bishop is a little bit dangerous
there are some checks here when okay the white
king can run away but even if you have to give a
bit of material back when you're lots of material
up it's often a good way to simplify get rid of
any nasty tactics and i like this move rook takes
e4 the point of this is after rook d4 the king is
very safe on a3 and all of these pieces protect
and they attack at the same time and really now
get the hoover out it's a mop up job and as we
can see magnus throws in a couple of checks but
the rook is clearly stronger than two pawns that's
something we should all know the game goes on but
it ends in a great victory for duda and i have to
say quite a you know quite an important moment in
chess history because magnus had this great streak
the longest ever streak of 125 wins but the duder
stops it what can we say about that well you know
he went for it magnus with the black pieces and
it was bound to end his undefeated streak so
i don't think he should be too disappointed i
mean clearly if he is worried about the streak he
wouldn't have played in this dangerous manner but
also all praise to white the duda keeps his cool
he grabs the material he defended perfectly and he
got a very important historical win there i'm sure
magnus will bounce back but we'll have to wait
until tomorrow to see how he's going to cope with
this loss he's not used to losing after all now do
remember to like this video and subscribe to the
channel and i'm sure i'll see you all again soon